hello everyone and welcome back to the
world chess championship 2021 it's
magnus cross and versus yanipanishi and
this is uh well game four the first
three games were very exciting or rather
the first two games were very exciting
the third one maybe not so much that uh
some of you or to most of you uh even
though it was proclaimed that the most
accurate world chess championship game
ever played uh no one really cares much
about that because we're interested in
in human moves pretty much so you know
it being the the most accurate game ever
played uh i i don't think that uh really
impresses anyone all that much you know
and unless you're keeping you know
statistics uh but uh if you remember
game one was uh
well there was some fighting game one
game two there was plenty of fight
magnus had a beautiful knight on d6 for
the entire game and well he sacrificed
the exchange later nipple had to give
back the exchange uh magnus was upon and
in the end the the players agreed to a
draw magnus again at the uh you know uh
give up that night for a night and and
upon for rook uh in game three we had
that early draw and now everyone is
wondering will we have a repetition of
game two where magnus went for that uh
crazy 95 catelyn with the white pieces
or will we have something else so before
we check out the game uh let's check out
uh some some photos here uh we have a
nice incoming hand change by uh by
nipple here uh you can see that nipple
is attempting to establish a full eye
contact here and the magnus not sure
whether to accept the eye contact or not
uh if you checked
the actual video i think there was a
moment where the eye contact was
established for a brief moment but but
only for a brief moment but nipple went
uh in for it uh very uh very bravely as
you can see and also this is the
gentleman that made the first move for
magnus i have no idea who that is if you
guys know uh do share in the comments so
we can all increase our our vast
knowledge uh that being said let's check
it out magnus has the white pieces and
no he does not open with the d4 he opens
with e4 and this is uh at the moment
where we find out what nepo has prepared
for e4 uh of course he uh prepared e5
knight to f3 we have knight to f6 so not
going for some sort of a rue lopez or uh
or maybe an italian game uh with black
but rather going for the petrol defense
or the russian defense and well this can
go many many ways if you guys remember
uh magnus and the corona played this in
the in their 2018
london match so here we have knight
captures on e5 going for the classical
variation accepting this pawn even if
only temporarily d6 knight back to f3
and the knight captures on a on e4
nipple now wins back the pawn and now
you could continue with something like
knight to c3 this is a very interesting
line where white you know gets his pawns
doubled very early on in the game but he
will get a lot of development for this
but here magnus just continues with the
so-called classical attack we have d4d5
bishop to d3 and now bishop to d6 we
have castles by both sides uh and now
white plays c4 so if you've ever studied
the petrov and you know you tried even
employing it in one maybe classical game
chances are you had this exact same
position on the board so we have c6
adding more protection to the d5 pawn
rook to e1 and now bishop to f5 so this
is all very standard stuff many many
games in the database with all of these
exact same ideas uh and here by playing
bishop to f5 uh nipple weakened the b7
pawn so queen to b3 going after the b7
pawn and queen to d7 nicely defending
this spawn we have knight to c3 now
putting more pressure here on the center
uh and nipple trades on c3 we have
knight captures now bishop captures an
f5 forcing the queen to move queen
captures on f5 b captures on c3 and now
as the b7 pawn is still hanging we have
b6
uh c captures on the e5 c captures uh
and now queen to b5 so again this has
all been seen before a very stifling
move by by magnus uh not allowing this
knight to to to develop you can't really
uh do all that much with the e8 square
both the queen and the rook are
controlling that so it's really time to
get rid of that queen from uh from b5 so
nepo goes back queen to d7 and now we
have a4 by magnus the idea is as black
has two pawns on the queen side and
magnus has only one you can use this one
pawn at the sort of blockade
the two pawns black has
nepal captures on b5 and here uh we have
a captures on b5 uh we have a5 now uh of
course if you don't play this if you if
you you know just develop uh it's it's
very hard to do something about it if
you play knight to d7 then how are you
ever getting this rook into the game
this pawn will be a target for for the
rest of the game so you have to play a5
and uh well uh of course you're
expecting b captures on a6 alpha
but not uh
this is not what happens so this is a
known move but the move magnus plays is
not a known move he plays knight to h4
and it's a really weird move but also as
of move 18 we have a completely new game
and uh you you can't really just uh come
up
with this idea because it's not even in
the first three engine recommendations
uh the engine in fact says it's not a
move that's all that impressive but it's
what magnus played and now uh what can
nipple play well of course we do not
want to allow knight to f5 so enable
played a g6 fairly quickly
of course we want to prevent this knife
from reaching this square and now we
have g4 by magnus
we have knight to d7 now you can
continue development as your a5 pawn is
nicely placed here and also it's a past
pawn so if white is not careful that
pawn could be star could start running
down the board
and here we have knight the g2
now with the knight can come for example
to e3 and it will put pressure on that
d5 pawn and also it controls the f4
square so you can play bishop to f4 if
you want to challenge black's strong
bishop on d6 uh and here ian spent some
23 minutes contemplating his next move
and uh he decided to play rook f the c8
and this is the
uh a very important move in the game as
i believe this is not what um uh what uh
carlson and his team had in mind when
they chose this position for this game
or rather chose this um
opening idea uh the uh the thing is they
probably thought he would go knight to
f6 first because it kind of comes with
tempo you attack the g for pawn uh we're
gonna attack the rook first bishop to h6
but now you can't really bring the rook
to c8 because the knight will come to e3
and put pressure on that d5 pawn so for
example rook after d8 and now knight to
e3 we defend our g4 pawn while we put
pressure on the d5 pawn and now bishop
to f8 we want to remove this bishop from
h6 let's say bishop g5 king g7 and this
is maybe one of the positions that uh
magnus and the team had in mind uh but
uh nipple after spending some 23 minutes
decided to play rook f2c8 and now it's a
bit of a different story the c3 pawn now
is hanging so how do you react to this
well there's only one good way to react
to this and that's to not react to it
here's a bishop to f4
so putting pressure on this bishop
and the idea is of course if bishop
captures knight captures then we are
attacking the d5 pawn then attacking the
b6 spawn and hopefully we're going to be
attacking a lot of pawns and here again
after some consideration not a lot
nipple both nipple and magnets played
their moves fairly quickly
nipple did spend a bit more time uh but
in the end he played bishop captures on
f4 an interesting move here is bishop
back to b8 it's uh you know not not in
anyone's way you do disconnect the rooks
for for a moment uh but the downside is
that you allow rook to e7 and you you
never want to allow this rook lifter
while the bishop was on d6 you were
guarding that e7 square but let's say
knight to f6 we're going to play rook to
b7 go after the b6 pawn now we're going
to play knight to e4 we're going to go
after the c3 pawn and now let's say rook
captures on b6 now we capture on f4 and
after knight captures knight captures on
c3 and it's a you know very interesting
position where white black still has
this beautiful a pawn
but white has the past b pawn but it
again uh if you're not uh you know uh
playing this with surgical precision it
it doesn't uh appear like you're gonna
be able to do anything here so after
bishop to f4 we have bishop captures on
f4 this is sort of the main line of this
combination knight captures an f4 we
have rook captures on c3 and knight
captures on d5 attacking the rook uh
here putting pressure on the b6 pawn and
also uh well with ideas of knight to f6
check if this knight ever moves from d7
we have rook to d3 going after the d4
pawn and the magnus goes for the rook
cliff to rook to e7 and now you have to
be careful here your knight is hanging
if the knight moves the b6 pawn is
hanging if you're really not careful
rook to c1 to c7 and then you really
have problems along the seventh rank so
here nipple plays knight to f8 it's the
only good square
for the knight and basically the only
move black has and now
again you have to figure out how to
continue this magnus spent over 20
minutes on his next move because there's
quite a lot to consider uh for example
you could just grab the pawn knight
captures on b6 uh then we have okay the
rook is attacked we have to move the
rook rook to b8 attacks the knight
knight moves back we're going to capture
on d4 uh you could capture something
else you could capture on b5 you could
capture on d4 you could first bring the
knight into the game so it really
doesn't matter but let's say rook
captures on the e4 knight to f6 with
king g7 we're going to play knight the
e8 check and now even king to h6 is
possible so there are positions that
could be reached this way for example
rook captures an a5 we get rid of this
nasty pawn rook after sanji for with the
chair king to f1 and you continue
playing this game with sort of equal
material uh well for the moment uh with
the exact equal material but it's a very
unbalanced and
magnus decides against it so instead
instead of this capture he could play
rook 8 to e1 also a very interesting
move just double up on the e file and
try to put immense pressure on the black
king's position but now let's say rook
captures on d4 again knight to f6
checking g7 and g5 now
looks looks very very interesting uh but
now black starts pushing the pawn a4 and
well knight d8 checking g8 knight to f6
checking g7 i28 check we we get a a
three-fold repetition so instead after
knight to f8 magnus did not go for
either of those two ideas he went knight
to f6 check first uh king to g7 and now
he repeats knight to e8 check king g8
and now we have d5 now you could also go
for the repetition here and you know
just claim a draw but you have the white
pieces and uh the thing is regardless of
what white plays and regardless of what
black plays you can always play this
idea on the next move so you know you
might as well try something so here
magnus goes for d5 it's a very nice pawn
push it's a pass pawn and you cannot
capture it if you capture a knight f6
check and the rook is just lost so here
after this d5 move uh what can nipple
play well uh you have to start pushing
the pass pawn the the pass pawn you know
it's like uh
when it's here it's uh you know a in an
order of magnitude uh weaker than when
you push it here and then you know again
here again here it just grows in
strength tremendously so here magnus
goes knight to f6 with check king to g7
and now everyone thought that he was
just going to repeat the position
because this is kind of a strong pass
pawn
but for the moment g5 so uh he puts more
pressure on yepos king and nepo just
continues pushing a3 now look at this
past pawn already on a3
looking incredibly dangerous and here
there are so many things you can
consider we're going to show some of
them we're going to explain uh well two
of my favorite ones
but magnus spent almost 40 minutes here
so some 35 minutes but he then you know
repeated the position a little bit and
then considered the position a bit more
uh so what can you play here where well
uh popular choices are h4 of course
maybe going for some h5h6 action king
the g2 getting the king into the game
king to f1 there are ideas of rook the
c1 with a nice rook lift the c7 you
could also start advancing the pawn
right away with the d6 so i'm gonna show
you the two of my favorite ones is that
uh well if you can advance the pawn to
d6 it still can be captured because
knight to e8 check and now black has to
give up the rook uh in order not to lose
an entire rook you have to give up the
exchange so after d6 the problem is you
give up uh your control over the e6
squared then black can go knight to the
e6 and then after d7 we can easily block
it rook to d8 and now after rook the e8
putting pressure
on that rook you don't care the rook's
defended by the knight you can just play
h6 for example attack the g5 pawn h4
we're gonna play captures captures and
now uh you might even try something like
rook three to g7
uh trying to give up that uh
uh exchange for for for a pawn and a
piece but white can play rook characters
on e6 let's say f captures any six
knight captures on d7 rook captures on
d7 and now rook captures an a3 but now
when you look at the position and white
didn't really achieve all that much rook
d5 and it's black who's attacking the
two pawns uh so
white can't really claim that he
achieved anything so that's what happens
after d6 or you know the best thing that
could happen for white uh but there is
the very interesting rook to see one
move so you just completely don't care
about a2 a1 and you want to play rook to
c7 and check made the black king so if
this is possible
and probably something that magnus spent
quite a lot of time working out then you
should definitely play it so let's see
how this plays out
ponte a2 of course and now there are two
options do we go rook c to c7 and allow
a1 queen
well if you allow this then a1 queen
comes with check that's one of the
problems came to g2 and now okay it
doesn't seem like black can do any more
checks and this looks very scary however
there are many ways black can avoid
getting checkmated king the h8 being one
of them
and now after rook captures on f7 we can
play rook to h3 looks uh
very nasty but uh at least we're
defending that h7 pawn three times with
the rook with the knight and the king
even though we're sacrificing a whole
rook here but there isn't a good move if
you capture it then we just play queen
to f1 check and slowly but surely the
white king will get checked maybe rook
to e3 checking f4 queen captures on f2
with check king e5
you can deliver some checks here and
well uh long story short you will get uh
checkmated very very uh nastly here so
here after rook to c1 and a2 you can't
really go for this rook uh
rook one to c7 idea but you can go for
rook captures on f7 also a very nice
idea and after king captures an f7 rook
to c7 check now look at this the pawn
cover is e6 the knight covers e8 uh the
rook of course covers e7 and the g7 the
knight covers g8 so what can you do here
it seems like the black king is
checkmated well almost because you can
block with the knight knight to d7 then
we capture the knight with this rook
move king to f8 and now after knight
captures an f7 check we have um this uh
well-known setup where uh well it's just
a draw because white can continue
perpetually checking the black king for
example if you go to here we're just
going to play knight f6 check check the
king defend the rook you're going to go
back we we again repeat this and you if
you attack the knight then we just play
knight back to f6 with check and you
have to go back here because if you go
here you get checkmated so there's that
so you're gonna have to go here knight
h7 check and so on and so on so this is
one of the options so rook to c1 as
interesting as it is it does not work
because this pawn is on a3 if it was on
a4
well that would be a completely
different story but it's not and all the
other moves they're just not fast enough
nipples pawn already on a3
is just a monster so here at knight the
e8 checked by magnus like i said after
some 35 minutes of uh thinking about the
position king g8 knight to f6 checking
g7 knight to the e8 check king to g8 and
the knights to f6 check and he was in
this position on move 33 that magnus and
nipple resigned oh sorry uh agreed to a
draw uh as there is nothing more uh to
be done here as you've seen so i i
thought uh magnus was trying to as today
is his 31st birthday i thought that he
was uh trying to make it so they agreed
on drawing move 31 but they in fact
agreed uh on move 33
i guess maybe it was sort of his plan
but it didn't work out who knows maybe
it's a silly thing you know but you know
he he's done sillier things so it could
be it could be you know what he was
going for
uh but yeah that's game four so no crazy
cattle and uh this time we've seen a
nice nice patter of defense we'll see uh
what will magnus go for in game six will
it be
a d4 and e4 or maybe even something else
so so it's not very often that you will
see
you know such deviations usually if you
try something in one game then you will
improve on it and employ it right in the
next one but here not so much from d4
straight to e4 we'll see what happens in
the next one
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it game five coming up next
uh i would like to thank may the fork be
with you frederick jacobson uh mayor um
mark epstein atarsh karpiak darsun uh
come captain and michael brooks for a
condition to my channel thank you a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
world chess championship until it ends
uh thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day